a lot of new young writers I've been
really excited about some of whom we've
published in The Paris Review Benjamin
Percy is a grade writer from Oregon who
published a first as published a couple
books now publisher collection called
refresh refresh which is moving kind of
in a kind of tradition of masculine
American fiction but also very funny and
tender and interesting Jessie ball is
another writer who I think is who's
who's roughly my age who's incredibly
profound and funny and we really weird
style that that that to me is I think
the most appealing writing dunk being
done now by a young writer that I know
of and who else said women should know
have to think about it some more I read
a lot of really bad short stories a lot
of my day is taken up by reading a lot
of really average short stories or um or
really bad short stories and when I find
something that's really good at I get
really excited Danielle Evans is another
young writer who excited about a short
story collection she has coming out soon
de nom and guessed you had a first novel
this year called the beautiful things
that heaven bears I believe that was
excellent these are all writers who are
30 or under their bats and I think are
doing really exciting things and things
that I really admire
you